while racing fans stay glued to the
grandstand's actual glue lines the Las
Vegas Motor Speedway here for now
they're running out and it's affecting
what they can safely do
Racers know it as traction compound the
sticky black chemical mixture that
glazes any drag strip we're not talking
about Elmer's Glue Trey agner and others
in the racing Community call it car glue
because it's gonna keep the car grounded
it's gonna make sure that it's under
control at all times give it more grip
to the to the track itself to where it's
going straight rather than kind of
veering off right or left but pandemic
related shortages amongst key
manufacturers are sticking Nationwide
the Las Vegas Motor Speedway announced
the cancellation of multiple racing
events on social media after weeks of
unsuccessful attempts they say to secure
more to do it without it I think would
be putting a lot of people in danger so
I think that we got to adapt and change
fortunate for this strip an undisclosed
glue supplier donated extra barrels to
save the Speedway's annual Thanksgiving
bracket Nationals but Across the Nation
other races not as lucky but I do know
that they're talking about going from a
quarter mile uh dragstrip down to an
eighth mile uh maybe no more racing
except from once a month it's unclear
when and how the shortage would end it
also is unclear what it means for future
events here on the drag strip reporting
from the Las Vegas Motor Speedway Ryan
mathie 8 News Now